I wanted to ask you a few things about that.
From the Big 5 personality theory research has been done into political differences.
This shows that liberals score high on openness and low on care.
For conservatives that is the other way around.
You can further divide care into orderliness and diligence with the Big 5 aspect scale.
Orderliness is strongly associated with disgust.
Haidt: that sounds very Freudian.
Indeed, it sounds that way.
But it also fits with your observations that, for example, conservatives keep their spaces tidier.
Haidt: And their meetings start on time.
Exactly, haha.
So there seems to be a connection between political views and being open to new experiences, urge to explore, which you mentioned
researching ideas and creativity, and little orderliness.
And then I thought: why should political views be associated with these personality dimensions?
These have relatively little correlation among themselves.
Then I thought, and this is in line with your disgust work,
that it is actually about limits.
That seems self-evident after Trumps election campaign, in which he spoke about boundaries.
But you could reasonably say that conservatives want to keep the boundaries between categories intact.
At every level of analysis.
From the highest level of refinement in thinking to the physical level of the boundaries of rooms, cities, states, countries, everything.
These limits must be stricter.
Why do they want that? There was an article in PLoS One a few years ago.
It was staggering, as far as I was concerned, it should have been front-page news.
The researchers had investigated the correlation in different countries and provinces within countries
between the prevalence of infectious diseases and authoritarian political views.
They found an enormously high correlation, something like 0.6.
For those unfamiliar with social science research, such a high correlation is never found.
Haidt: Except in the case of heredity.
Indeed, except in the case of heredity.
So they found that the higher the prevalence of infectious diseases, the more people tended to totalitarian, authoritarian political views.
And then they ruled out the influence of the local government,
for they wanted to know whether this belief in authority was imposed from above, or had developed from below.
The latter turned out to be the case.
I approached this from two perspectives at the same time.
We have established the link between sensitivity to disgust and orderliness.
You can call this a fundamental component.
Then I read the book of Hitler's table discussions.
It contains the contents of everything Hitler said at dinner between 1939 and 1942.
His spontaneous expressions.
It contains many discussions of Jews and gypsies and all the people he tormented.
But what's interesting: all his language is full of disgust. No fear.
Hitler's basic metaphor was that the Aryan race and country was a pure body.
And that it was attacked by parasites.
Then I remembered what happened to the original Americans when the Europeans appeared and shook hands with them.
95% of them died of chickenpox and measles within 50 years.
So the subject of borders distinguishes conservatives from liberals.
Conservatives say: what's new is potentially contaminated.
Not so dangerous, that is different, that would be fear, but it is infected.
Liberals say: wait a minute, if you make the boundaries too firm, information can no longer pass through.
Haidt: Exact. That is the omnivore's dilemma.
Right. And because we have a biological structure on which our cognitive constructions rest
we approach abstract information, such as ideas, the same as food, or illness.
So we can find ideas invasive, or polluting, or contaminated.
Haidt: I'm a big fan of George Lakoff's Metaphores We Live By.
We use our body schemas to think about abstract things like politics.
About what the policy on borders and immigration should be.
A Canadian psychologist, Mark Schaller, and his colleagues developed a theory about this 'behavioral immune system'.
Bacteria probably killed many more of our ancestors than lions, tigers and bears.
So if you can protect yourself and your children against deadly diseases, you are the winner in evolution.
Much depends on careful assessment of people: is he dangerous? Is she dangerous?
That applies to sex and other interpersonal intercourse.
So yes, our emotions and our physical interactions shape how we think and feel about things ...
Even with the plague epidemic in Europe, which appeared when Europeans started traveling the world and brought rats that were infected.
There you saw those forces at work at the same time.
The European expansion produced a great exchange of ideas from all over the world, that is globalization.
But it also eradicated between 30 and 60% of the population.